I want to cut to the chase on what cop21
will do do you actually believe that
cities can scale to give us a better
energy world versus what nations and
states can do well that question
actually is very is very interesting but
let me first start by saying that this
is a great earth day for our stewardship
of the climate of the earth now in terms
of cities cities clearly have to play an
important role as you as you know we're
well past now fifty percent urbanization
globally will be at seventy percent
probably by mid-century and cities do
present interesting opportunities
precisely because of their of the
density certainly we could see much much
greater electrification of cities served
by carbon free sources we can see
opportunities for efficiency in how
people live so cities are going to play
a critical role and another issue which
has been emphasized recently is how
urban areas and the networking of urban
areas in different regions can play a
very important part in going to a
low-carbon future I like the idea of
networking of urban areas have you seen
a change in your tenure within the
climate deniers there are people out
there that just flat out say Jeff Sachs
is wrong Ernest Moniz is wrong cop 21 s
wrong if they changed their tone over
the last say two years I think so but
let me also say that my very first day I
guess even before being on the job
formally I made it clear that I did not
come to Washington to debate what's not
debatable I'm happy to debate of course
exactly how we implement our programs to
address climate change now I do think
there is a shift and that shift is
driven by the realities of what the
public is seeing the realities that
certainly polls show the public clearly
understanding that we need to address
climate change again we still have
debates going on about what exactly to
do how to do it we
have different regional questions that
need to be addressed but it is not
credibly debatable that we we need to be
prudent and address climate change in a
in a strong way so secretary Moniz do
you expect to ratify the agreement from
Paris not just sign it but ratify it
before President Obama's term is up well
again today as you as you've said what
we will see is the vast majority of
countries signing on to the agreement
there's a second step that involves
internal processes to to denote
acceptance the United States and China
have announced that both of us plan to
reach that stage this year so the answer
is yes we are going through the internal
processes to reach acceptance this year
how do you get from the current deal
pledges on the table adding up to three
degrees of warming to the below two
degrees actually signed on well the
Paris Accord in my view is a very very
major first step it's a first step
because as you've implied exercising our
programs internationally will again
bring down global warming expectations
dramatically but by themselves they will
not get us below two degrees there's no
there's no question there but that's why
the agreement also has five year review
periods why there is the anticipation of
greater ambition in the future and one
of the critical issues there rests on
another Paris Paris discussion being
implemented namely something called
mission innovation that's where 20
countries have come together and pledged
to seek a doubling of energy all right
the United States among them and we
believe that that will lead to more
innovation that will lead to more cost
reduction and more cost reduction will
lead to more ambition mr. secretary let
me bring in Jeffrey Sachs of Columbia
University with a question for you Jeff
first I want to say how nice it is to be
with you mr. secretary and
it's nice the agent America has one of
the smartest people in our country is
secretary of energy it's it's really a
great thing Ernie I wonder if you could
say a word about the nuclear future in
our country that's a low-carbon energy
source it provides still a substantial
part of our electricity highly
controversial many of us think it needs
to be part of a low-carbon future for
the u.s. how do you see the politics and
the thinking and the technology on this
now this is a narrative your great
expertise well certainly we the
president and I agree need to keep
nuclear on the table as an option
essentially a zero-carbon option for the
future the challenge with nuclear power
at least a major challenge of nuclear
power is that with today's reactors
certainly there's a very very large
upfront capital cost although a
comparatively low operating costs given
the that capital structure what we are
seeing is new reactors being built in
the southeast where the the rate
recovery mechanisms are operative we
will see how that propagates across the
country but you mentioned technology and
as one example of something that I
certainly think it's very important for
us to see through is the development of
much smaller so-called modular reactors
indeed the Department of Energy has
helped support now a company on that and
they will be submitting a design
certification its a 50 megawatt rather
than say a twelve hundred megawatt
reactor they will submit this year to
the NRC